[موسيقى]
كاس العالم فكره فرنسيه بامتياز بدات من
روبرت غورن عام
1904 اول رئيس للفيفا وانتهت عند مواطنه
جورميه بعد 24 عاما مؤسس المونديال الذي
دفع تكلفه اول كاس للعالم من ماله الخاص
في عام 1930 اقيم اول مونديال برعايه
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا
كاس جورميات تكريما له كان هذا الرجل
اداريا ماهرا اسس نادي ريد ستار متعدد
الرياضات وهو لم يبلغ الخامسه والعشرين من
عمره كان ذلك عام
1897 بدا في وضع خطوط للارتقاء بالمؤسسات
الرياضيه في بلاده وشارك في تاسيس الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم فيفا عام 1904
احكي لنا اندلاع الحرب العالميه الاولى
انها احلامه فالتحق ضابطا بالجيش الفرنسي
وقتها
رميه كان لديه حلم كبير يتلخص في اقامه
بطوله عالميه لكره القدم ما ان انتهت
الحرب العالميه الاولى حتى اسس الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم عام 1919 بعدها بعامين
اصبح رئيسا
لا قد استمعت رهيم من اجل ايصال فكرته
للعالم باقامه المونديال اكثر من تسع
سنوات مع صديقه لوني السكرتير العام
للفيفا وهما يحاولان اقناع المهتمين بكره
القدم حول العالم باقامه هذه البطوله
الكبرى نجح رني اخيرا وحقق ما اراد ففي
مؤتمر الفيفا عام 28 فزيخ صدر قرار
تاريخيا باقامه وتنظيم المونديال الاول في
تاريخ اللعبه كاس العالم عام
1930 في الاوروبيه
[تصفيق]
لقد اصبح جورنياي والد هذا الكاس واباها
الروحي وعلى الفور بدا البحث عن هذا
الفنان كي ينحت هذه الايقونه العالميه
الجديده تم اسناد صنع الكاس للنحات
الفرنسي قبل الفلور والتكلفه كانت من جيب
رمليه شخصيا لكن وقعت مشكله كادت تنهي
الحلم الكبير
منتخبات العالم لم تؤكد مشاركتها في
مونديال عام 30 كان الامر عاصيبا على
المحامي الفرنسي
قبل البطوله بنحو شهرين فقط لم يؤكد اي
منتخب مشاركته رميه تدخل شخصيا لاقناع
اربع دول اوروبيه بالمشاركه
بدات البطوله وحمل ريميكاسه في حقيبته
الخاصه واتوجه للاوروغواي ومنذ تلك اللحظه
تولى الرجل تنظيم خمس بطولات موندياليه
اخرى كان اخرها مونديال عام 54 ثم اعتزل
بعدها العمل الرياضي عندما تخطف ثمانين من
عمره لتظل هذه الكاس محل تنافس لمده تسعه
بطولات عالميه الى ان فازت البرازيل
باللقب عام 70 واحتفظت بكاس جرميل للابد
ومن بعدها تغير شكله وتصميم الكاس حتى
اصبحت بهذا الشكل